the vikings have not gotten over the
hump ever
as i know very well from my childhood
and 50 years later here we are
but that doesn't mean that they are
looking for an upgrade at quarterback
general manager rick spillman who will
be with us tomorrow on pftpm pending
anything i may say over the next few
minutes that could cause him to decline
the invitation here's spielman talking
to the media about kirk cousins earlier
today
yeah i think coach zim put that to bed
when he spoke after the season kirk
cousins is our quarterback i know
there's a lot of
rumors floating around out out there but
kirk cousins is our quarterback we felt
that he played very well and probably
the best uh he's ever played down that
stretch last year and the way he played
so um that we yeah kirk kirk's got
quarterback gordon ford and uh look
forward to him another year in his
system
and uh and excited for him and what he's
going to bring to our team next year
[Music]
huh look i i've had fun with rick
spielman over the years from 2013 we
have no intent to trade percy harvin
last year i asked him at the scouting
combine just before the world turned
upside down look into the camera and
tell us that you're not going to trade
stefan diggs and he said stefan diggs is
a member of the vikings and
he did a little he did a little
as he was talking about looking forward
to the season with kirk cousins i just
think he had an itch i'm going to give
him the benefit of the doubt now because
my take on this is very simple
they can't trade kirk cousins
because
if they do
they're they're not going to be good
enough with someone else to save jobs
and i think this is one of those years
where they got to be thinking about
saving jobs spielman's included in my
opinion
you know they're on this roller coaster
plan in minnesota
even year no playoffs odd year playoffs
that's been the trend since 2014 when
mike zimmer became the coach playoffs 15
17 19 no playoffs 14 16 18 20.
and last year everybody everybody got
extensions cousins and spielman and
zimmer and dalvin cook i said don't let
everybody
work the final year of the contract good
problem to have would be they all have a
great year and the vikings have a great
year and then you reward everybody after
that so
i think that they're concerned if they
would move kirk cousins unless they get
an obvious desean watson or russell
wilson in return
you're not moving kirk cousins and uh
that's a problem for the vikings because
they're on the hook for 56 million over
the next two years and cousins told us
four weeks ago super bowl week he's not
interested in redoing that contract he's
got two more years with minnesota and
then he's going back to the open market
the way things are going to work with
franchise tags and all that he'll be
back on the open market in two years and
the vikings have to compete with other
teams if they want to keep them beyond
2022 shireen
yeah my gm's lie and rick spillman as
you pointed out has lied in the past i
have no doubt he's telling the truth in
this case because he and mike zimmer are
going to go in next year perhaps
strategic
strategic manipulation of reality
yeah truth at the time maybe but
they're going to go into next season on
the hottest of hot seats perhaps perhaps
as the hottest hot seat for a coach and
the hottest hot seat for a gm and
kirk cousins gives them the best chance
to save their jobs when you look at what
he's averaged in his career over 4 000
yards in the three years he's been in
minnesota 30 touchdowns 10 interceptions
the failure for the vikings this past
season frankly had more to do with their
defense which was 29th and yards allowed
they need to upgrade that defense so
they can get to the postseason with with
kirk cousins and i think mike that
probably saves their jobs for another
season how long that will save their
jobs i don't know but i think it will at
least get them another season to try to
either upgrade at quarterback or upgrade
the roster or whatever you think you
have to do to take that next steps
because at some point you have to take
that next step and they haven't been
able to do that but they have been to
the playoffs with kirk cousins and think
they can get back there this next year
and perhaps they can with this roster
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports